BRD RIGHT NOW. CNN'SNG NE. R
CAUSHI
YOU LEARNING, KARA?ELF TEL AND
LLER, THATN
RAND
INEDNT DONALD
TRUMP INN THE
HUSHAYMENTSCHEME. THI
INUNRCOINS, AND THEEXACT CHARGEI
INVESTIGATION HASING ON
INDICTME FORMER PRESIDENTIS THEN
CHARGES YET. WE EXPECT T TO BE N
THER ORIDT TO
COME TO THIS BE
ARRANGED WOLFY
DID MEET TODAY, EVEN THOUGH
THEYT
WE
THEREAFTER,HEAND PRESUMABLY, THE
VOTED ON THIS INDICTMENT TODAY.E
RE MEETING TODAY. WE WLD WULED T
JANUARYSSTESTIM,  IPROSECUTORS Y
WEREOING TO MOVEOR
DI TO ASK THAT
JURY TO VOTE. IT APPRS IN AHETS
GRAND JURY MEETS FIVE PM APPEAR
CAME DOWN. JUST
CO MINUTES WITHIN
LAST VERYC I, FIRST TIME
UNITED STATES HAS BEORYAT A
INDICTED IN A CRIMALVESTIGATIONS
LEGAL AFFAIRS
CORRESPONDENT PAULA REID, WHO IS
ALSO FOLLONG
WITH ONEASL THEY H TBYUTORS ABOG
OUED SEVEN YEARS A
FIVE YEARS. BUT INNT THIS INIGE
WISEOS
OTHER
BEFORE THE GRA J TESTIFY
WAS ANTICIPATION THAT
THIS INVESTIGA WAS
COMING TO AN END. AND SARAH AND
JO JUST REPORTED APPEARS THE
TO INDICT.
TTORNEY HAS SE HAS
ENR BY SOME
NOTS MORE
AGGRESSIVELY. AND THEN WHEN ISIR
HE SHOULOITH THIS,
ARGUING THAT THISAS NOT
THE MORE SNIMER
PRESIDENT WOULD CLEITH
THE GRANDURET ASHAS BEEN
EXPLAINED TO US THEA'. WHAT NEXG
SURRENDER. FROMORMER
PR HAVE BEEN TOLD BY
APPEARED THAT THE FORMERE T
PRESIDENT ABSOLUTELY WANTED TO
ERN ANDPARTICIPATE IN THE PROCES
BEING FINGERDPHOTOGRAPHED
JUDGE AS ANY OTHERIZ W
. THE FORMER PRESIDENTEARSTHIS N
ADVANTAG THING FOR HIM
POLILL,
INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT THE
HE UL TO ACTUALLYSURRENDUR
AND LIKAN. S CITIZEERPRINTEDOUGT
WERE INDTE. RIGHT.E AE,
TR CIRBE SERVICE. THERE AREGNIFA
CIRCUS ON A GOOD D SO THEY'ABSOT
LEAN  WANTS
AND REALLY
A THING OUT OF THIS BECAUSE
THIS INDTMAT POLITICAY,
IT TRULYEVELOPLDING IN NEW YORKR
OOU THINK?  THIS IS HISTORICTHIT
LEION ARE SAYG, SN
LOOK, IT'S NOT AS IMPORTANT A
WHIGHT BE
MIN IN TERMS
OF THE ATLANTA I AND IN A
MA T, AN
EARLY ONCTIONEAST WHIRUMP HVAARU
SEON WE'RE GOING TO
OUT BEFE HASKED. AND TT,
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE
MAABN
HAVE DIFFERENT INTERPRETATIONS
OF IT. HE'S GO T VICTIM, ETCETE.
INDICTMENT. WE NEED  IT SAIS A T
TR SEVERAL YEARS NOWOLANTZND
SHE' JWH ELSE ARYOU LEARNITELANR
FORMERTH
SINCE. SAID THAT HELAST TSD TOPA
OUAT THA
TIME. THEY I DIDN'T RY HAVE
INTO WHAT THE TIMING
HERE W TO LOOK LIKE THEY
WHAT WE AS OF
YESTERDAY, WHICHASWAS POTENTIALA
HIATUS. TURY. BUT THIS NED
THE QN IS WHAT
EC
ATTORNEYS HE  THAT HE WILL
THATE O  GO
THROUGH NE STEPS WHERE
HE'S GOINGEDOR
FTM
LOOKS LIKE. WE DON'T KNOW HOW
SOON THAT WILL HAPPEN. IT COULD
TAKE SEVERAL DAYS
, DELEGATE OR INTRITE. LAT THATG
EXES HE'SGNTE IFAL
AS TYPICALLY IS THE CASE HERE
MANHTANOWTHAT IS G TO BE AN I
TEYT'OMETHING THEY BELIEVE IS
A T CAN
INDICTED TE FOR HIM. HE DOES NOT
SITUATIONSOR E. CERTAINLY NOTASY
OON A DAILY BASIS
MEO
ABOUT THESE PAYMENTS. B
INVOLVES ALLEGATIOBO AN
T W SOMETHING THA
RUMP AT THE TIME, ANSO IT ER
K AT HE WANTED TOICTED DOES NOTT
ANY OF THORTING THAT I'VE
HADCE IS  T. S.
PRESIDENT FME U. S PRESIDENTL CN
HOMESR AL
IS SOHER STORIES SOURCES FOR U.
ARE LKRISTENFR NUMBER MEMBERS R
CIRCLE WHO ARE ALL T
FIUTXAG
YET HEARD.OT
OTTEN THE
PR FOR DO IN ORDER T
WA TALK ABOUT WHAT CAITLYNMENTIT
BNGP.. THEY
HOW EXACT
IS GOI IS A
NT
IS AO THEY
FACIAL EXPRESSIONS T
. WH HIN
M A STATEMENT? WHO IS HETO MAKA
DIDFTTALKED TO SOME ARE
CLOSE TP, WHO TALKED
PRENT
E FACTT
D MEENG THAT
CO FRONT OF
THE GRANDE SHOPE THAT MAT WASN'T
WEINBLPRIME ASS GOING TOEN
APPEAR, IN SOME IT T. THE
ILL AP ALLIES
AND ADVISERS, PEOPLE WHO ARE
OS WHO WANT HTHE NOMINATIONID
THK M IN
IT'SERNED ABOUT WHAT DO WITH HS
CLEAR. GO AHEAD. LET US ADD'VE T